There are few things more upsetting
than the idea of a lonely death.
To pass off the mortal coil without anyone around
you, anyone to comfort you in your final moments.
Thankfully, SCP-4999 exists to
help solve this tragic issue.
SCP-4999 is a humanoid who appears dressed in dark
formalwear. He manifests at the side of fatally
injured, critically ill, or otherwise dying people
within the last twenty minutes of their life.
He will only appear to those dying alone, sitting
or standing with them if no chair is available in
an act of what seems like silent respect. Next,
he will pull out two cigarettes: One for himself,
and one for his dying friend. He’ll then hold
their hand, place a hand on their shoulder,
or engage in some other kind of comforting
physical touch in their final moments,
then disappear shortly after the person has
passed, leaving no trace that he was ever there,
except for the left behind cigarette.
While no one is exactly sure what he is
or why he has chosen to keep his vigil,
thanks to SCP-4999, nobody ever really dies alone.